now this Republican Senator Ron Johnson
called out NBC's Chuck Todd yesterday on
Meet the Press after the host pressed
him on efforts to investigate the Biden
family Shady foreign business dealings
and things got a little testy take a
look
Senator do you have a crime that you
think Hunter Biden committed because
I've yet to see anybody explain it is
not a crime to make money off of your
last name
so Chuck you ought to read the Marco
Polo report where they detail all kinds
of potential crimes you know Senator
grass
potentials about 30 000 about 30 000
investigation I mean
chuck chuck is it a crime to be
soliciting and purchasing uh
prostitution in potentially European sex
trafficking operations is that a criter
I'll take your word that you're
ethically bothered by Hunter Biden I'm
curious though you seem to have you not
uh I'm a journalist
Chuck you know part of the problem and
this is pretty obvious to anybody
watching this is you don't invite me on
to interview me you invite me on to
argue with me look you can go back on
your partisan cable cocoon and talk
about media bias all you want I
understand it's part of your identity
now I'm a journalist I'm a journalist
I'm above all this I only deal in facts
and you know I I haven't seen any
evidence at all I I've been looking
really hard for evidence of Hunter Biden
but of course anyone who has looked at
the Biden family dealings with any sort
of objectivity knows that there's a
whole host of potential wrongdoings
right out there in the open as legal
scholar Jonathan Turley writes quote
while Todd just heaps insults upon those
who have called for investigations or
actually done them he previously gave
entirely non-confrontational and
supportive interviews softballs for
investigating the possible compromising
of Donald Trump
and ads about the bidens quote on the
influence peddling Scandal there are
foreign transfers gifts and other
matters that could prove Criminal
but it gets even worse for Hunter as
we're now learning that he's actually
fighting to prevent his daughter with
ex-lover London Roberts from using his
last name in a recent court filing in
Arkansas Hunter's legal team is seeking
to stop Robert's request to let the
four-year-old take his surname the Biden
name here for reaction Wisconsin Senator
the man himself Ron Johnson Senator
thanks for being here uh so he he has
the goal to kind of come out and say
I've yet to see any evidence at all
about has he looked and why won't he
take seriously those who have and
realize that the connection between
Hunter and Joe is not just a connection
between two private citizens but between
a private citizen and the president
well Pete well again if you don't look
for evidence you'll never find it and I
think Buck Sexton made a pretty good
point in the previous segment the
journalists who basically helped install
uh President Biden into his office they
called him a moderate they suppressed
and censored Senator Grassley my report
the hunter Biden laptop story they don't
want to defend his record 40 year high
inflation record gas prices a wide open
border Rising crime so again I am so
suspicious of this uh now revelation of
these documents they found them last
November and they didn't get them all
identified and they have a drip drip
drip uh
mm-hmm
revelation of these things coming out
it's just an absurd story it makes no
sense whatsoever but again the the
journalists don't want the egg on their
face they don't want to have to defend
this President because his his uh
policies have been disastrous for this
country
suspicious uh suspicious that of of the
of who might have wanted the these
Revelations to come out and the reason
for that
yeah it's just a bizarre story it makes
no sense whatsoever uh again if you find
these documents if you're working for
the president uh you you go to the
president and and if the president
wanted to to be up up and up and on this
thing and disclose it all he would look
in every nook and cranny cranny he'd
find every possibly every any possible
classified document and they would you
know release the story all at once they
wouldn't uh all of a sudden day after
day say oh we found some more documents
ooh in the garage oh in in a dresser
drawer somewhere I mean it's just a
bizarre story it makes no sense
uh someone like Chuck Todd when he's do
you think he ever makes an Earnest
effort to understand
any other side other than his home team
which he is clearly defending I mean he
calls himself a journalist he clearly
believes at some level that he's
somewhere in the middle are they are
they delusional or have they just lived
in that in that cocoon if you if I may
say for too long
well yeah unfortunately you have the
vast majority of people in the
mainstream media they're not journalists
anymore they're advocates for the
Democrat Party and so they see things
from a completely biased and slanted
view the Viewpoint of the left uh and so
like so many other leftists they they
don't believe that there's any other
Viewpoint that's valid uh so he just
simply won't open his eyes to the truth
and to the other Viewpoint he's not fair
in Balance he's not you know apparently
Fox News is the Cocoon Fox News is about
his fairness balance you can get you you
present both sides the mainstream media
doesn't do that
nope uh Meet the Press has been his own
personal cocoon now for many many years
and there's only one side coming out of
there you've done the investigation
you've done the work you put it out
there it was suppressed and it was
ignored they're choosing to ignore it
but we appreciate all the work you're
doing Senator Ron Johnson thanks for
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else